-Everyone, the NBA Draft
is tomorrow,
and earlier, I got to hang out
with a few of the top prospects
over Zoom and shoot
some virtual hoops.
And, you know, there's sore
losers and sore winners.
You know?
Let's just say that.
Anyways, let's take a look.
We had some fun.
Hey, guys, I'm here with
some of the top NBA prospects,
Anthony Edwards, James Wiseman,
and Obi Toppin,
and I thought it'd be fun
to challenge them
to a little two-on-two
on the only court
I might be able to keep up --
the PlayStation.
Let's do this.
Dude, I'm gonna talk smack.
I'm ready to go, man.
James, you're my teammate.
-Alright.
-Who are you gonna play with?
-I'm over here
with Kyrie Irving.
-I'm Kobe. Ant, who you getting?
-I'm Michael Jordan.
-Really? Kobe, Michel Jordan?
Alright, James,
who should I pick?
-Oh, yeah, Kareem.
-Oh, Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
I'll be Kareem.
[ Whistle blows ]
Alright, here we go.
-Alley-oop, alley-oop is L2,
Ant.
-Yow! Please!
How's it going, Jordan?!
All good!
Oh! [ Laughs ]
Oh, my God! It's a blowout!
-[ Laughs ]
-Yes! Oh, you bricked it!
-Why my man not shoot?
-It's not his fault, Ant.
Go, go, go, go, go, Kyrie, go.
-Get back.
-Oh, my gosh!
It's a one-man team.
I haven't done anything good
for the team at all.
But it doesn't matter, James.
We're on it.
Oh, my God! The skyhook!
-[ Laughs ]
-What's going on?
-Oh, my God! It's no contest!
-Hey, he know how to play, brah.
I don't know how to play.
-We good, we good.
-Jordan, don't hurt him.
-Dang, man.
-God darn it.
-Here we go, here we go.
-Oh!
-Gosh.
-I just slammed on y'all.
-Buh-tuh-tuh-tuh-tuh-tuh.
Ba-hoo!
Happy Thanksgiving.
There's the stuffing
in the turkey right there!
-Y'all cheating.
Y'all got hacks on here.
-[ Laughs ] I'm not cheating.
Obi. [ Laughs ]
Obi with the brick.
-Man!
-It's a close game, 33-18.
-We need to come back, Ant.
-Go, go, go, run,
run, run, turbo!
Boing!
-Ooh!
-Oy, oy, oy, oy, oy!
[ Whistle blows ]
-Guys, Team Jimmy Jams
for the win.
Good luck. I cannot wait to see
you guys in the NBA, man.
-Hey, Ant, we need to play them
in real life two-on-two.
-Yeah, for sure.
-Leave meeting, leave meeting,
leave meeting.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks again to
Anthony Edwards, James Wiseman,
and Obi Toppin!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The NBA Draft is tomorrow at
8:00 p.m. Eastern on ESPN.
Good luck to all the players.